so there's a new exhibit at the at the
bellagio gallery of fine arts
leather throwers highlights artists
who've utilized imagery and the
personalities of boxing to create
sculptures
paintings and even drawings several
local collectors have loaned their
pieces to the exhibit for the very first
time
leather throwers will be on display now
until august 22nd again
this is all at the bellagio gallery of
fine arts
another sight to see at the bellagio the
dazzling summer display at the
conservatory and we know the bellagio
goes
all out so this one is called the eco
season of earthly awareness
the designer says all elements earth
wind and fire
are represented he also shares what went
into this
and why it was so important to reuse
stuff from previous displays
so this is a 90 new exhibit we do have
some pieces that we've repurposed from
other exhibits which is
really kind of what we're all about but
this was a year and a half in the making
we actually started designing this
quite a long time ago and it's evolved
as we've gone along
and really become something very
magnificent they always do
amazing work out there you can catch the
display now through
august 28th